joining us now from Van Buren Arkansas
is Juanita Broderick who accuses Bill
Clinton of raping her in a hotel room in
1978 and from Little Rock Arkansas Paula
Jones who sued Bill Clinton for sexual
harassment he settled with her for eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars Paula
and Juanita it is great to see both of
you I'm just delighted that both of you
are here and Paula I want to start with
you what went through your mind when you
heard kirsten gillibrand today and make
basically mika brzezinski on NBC at
MSNBC both saying that oh yes bill
clinton should have resigned after the
after the Lewinsky affair well it's just
a little bit too late for that now isn't
it so it makes you wonder if they really
truly mean what they say because US
women's did not get any kind of help
whatsoever from any of those liberal
women they ridiculed us we were called
all kind of names we were not believed
and I just I hope that it's true that
they think that now but I don't know
that it's that I believe it Oh Juanita
what's happened between now and 1998
when your accusation really got a lot of
attention and when Lisa Myers bravely
pushed NBC to get that on the news I
mean what's changed except is that
Hillary is not president she's not in
the cabinet the Clinton Global
Foundation is is frankly has been
exposed as the fraud that it was with
the pay-to-play that was going on there
and so the Clintons aren't useful
anymore so now suddenly oh he was a he
shouldn't have done that he should have
resigned oh I know it's absolutely
disgusting Laura this great epiphany
that should have occurred 20 years ago
coming about now is I should feel
ecstatic about it but I don't
I feel very disappointed that they
waited two decades to do this were you
surprised Juanita that kirsten
gillibrand
didn't mention you I mean she mentioned
Lewinsky because of course that was the
sub
of the impeachment proceeding her
relationship led to the impeachment
because he lied under oath but he didn't
mention you he didn't mention Paula
he didn't mention Cathleen which she
didn't mention Kathleen Willey it was
only it was only Monica Lewinsky I
wonder why I think it's too dangerous to
bring us back up again they do not want
to hear from us Laura
and that's the crux of the matter they
do not want our names to be brought up
again and we're being brought up by
everybody else so I can't understand why
she didn't include us Paula and Juanita
I want you to listen to something that
Hillary Clinton said today in an
interview with our friend Rita Cosby on
WABC let's watch listen every situation
has to be judged on its own merits and
there were allegations that were
disproved it's unfortunate that people
are either misremembering
or misinterpreting history Paula
misremember I'm not no no no no no no no
that is so ludicrous what she just said
I mean seriously I cannot believe that
that lady would say that and nothing was
misinterpreted I know what happened to
me in that room that day and I also know
that there was some lady named from the
New York Times that had quoted some Miss
Goldberg lady said that she believed one
either which I'm happy because she
should believe one either but she also
should believe me too and she said that
that was not true about me well how
would she know unless she had some kind
of a relationship with him or something
that she's been looking at his private
parts you know how can she say that I
was discredited when I was not
discredited you know I mean the 8th
Circuit Court of Appeals was going to
take it all the way to trial and they
Bill Clinton settled why would he settle
if it would have been thrown out at a
lower court people don't do that if
you're if you're not guilty
well maybe Hillary Clinton's title title
of her book what her title of her book
what happened should apply to her yeah
we know what happened Juanita can you go
back to the to that horrible encounter
that you had with Bill Clinton
especially after he pushed you and your
lip got you know bitten basically or
hurt and what he said to you in that
room actually we yeah we have the sound
and really we're gonna play that again
from your let's play it from your
original interview let's watch second
time he tries to kiss me
he starts biting on my lip when
everything was over with he got up
straightened himself and I was crying at
the moment and he walks to the door and
calmly puts on his sunglasses it is
before he goes out the door he says you
better get some ice on that and he
turned to put some ice on out and yeah
yeah it's it's you know it's so painful
to hear it now you know even after all
these years it's it's disgusting and
painful you know and I want to know he
would not want to come to this I'm sorry
I just want to know why Hillary wouldn't
want to come and talk to us women see if
she believes it's not true then why was
she talk to us talk to each one of us or
talked to us together and then she can
come to a conclusion herself but she's
never ever she never even was asked
about us women during her campaign isn't
that ironic isn't that funny that none
of this come out about her womanizing
predatory husband who did up these women
so wrong all of us and it's just beyond
words that nobody will polish the goods
come out they said why wouldn't she want
to ask us well she threatened you you
know but she could at least have talked
to us and at least found out for herself
I mean and talk to us to see if how
credible we were but she didn't want to
you know why cuz she knew
she knows she'll be born here for years
no she did she's been enabling him for
years she's been hiding this stuff for
him for years if you know if you're
married to a man and you don't know that
your husband is doing this something is
wrong and you know they claim to have
such a wonderful marriage and she's
stood by her man but let me tell you she
knew what he was doing and the only
reason why they've ever stayed together
is because it was a political marriage
this is what I Philip Raines who's one
of them who is one of Phillip Raines
who's one of Hilary's former campaign
chiefs said this today let's listen
there's no human being in the United
States whose personal life they're in
Fidelity's were looked at more than Bill
Clinton his accusers were afforded the
opportunity to confront him he was
afforded the ability to defend himself
juanita were you afforded the ability to
confront a Bill Clinton oh gosh I think
I'll just laugh out loud right now
hilarious it's it's disgusting you know
no human being was protected more than
Bill Clinton was they built this wall
around him and no human being was more
harassed and ridiculed and trashed as
Bill Clinton's victims were I did get
him time to speak but it was only
because I had Lisa Myers she was one of
the very few who believed in me and just
stayed on that story until we got it
through and I commend telling me she was
forced to air it yeah NBC did not want
to air their report they were forced to
air that report no they let you close
this Paula like I'll let you let you
close this out Paula so these women now
mika brzezinski from MSNBC in in
Gillibrand and others who are now these
late hits against Bill Clinton do you
think there there might be any
credibility to what they're saying they
just may now see the horror of sexual
harassment
sexual assault or is this all politics
it's probably politics I mean I would
imagine that it probably was I just wish
that these people would mention our
names you know when they are very active
time and saying oh yeah we are
absolutely real people and but what gets
me to is they only mentioned Monica
Lewinsky she was a consensual person
that was doing stuff to Bill Clinton
under the oval office desk
we will not there's a different
different take on that so well do you do
either if you expect that Kirsten
Gillibrand might call you to talk to you
and do you expect a call from her I was
surely not I'm sure I really think
that's possible she's supposed to be Hey
ladies ladies ladies she's supposed to
be the be-all and end-all on sexual
harassment on Capitol Hill given the
historic nature of the Bill Clinton
assaults on women she should call you
she and she should have pot she should
apologize on behalf of all those
so-called feminists who covered for
Clinton all those years thank you both
for joining us tonight I know it was
really really a pleasure to see both of
you and we really appreciate your voice
thank you so much